jane do 16 ans je vis avec ma famille ma
soeur dans ce quartier assez tranquille
j'ai un chien et je pense mais tout
fonder une famille je suis passionnée
par l'art et j'adore voyager mais il a
mimé décrirais comme quelqu'un de gentil
et ponctuel bon probablement plus de la
moitié des personnes présentes dans
cette salle doivent se dire que je suis
quelqu'un de complètement banale et avec
raison
par contre comment réagiriez vous si je
vous disais que la personnalité que je
viens de vous décrire sa tablette ou
celle d'un robot capable de copier les
caractéristiques d'une personnalité
aussi bien que juste que je viens de
faire parce que cela sera bientôt le cas
la singularité technologique il
peut-elle supposant que la création de
l'intelligence artificielle amènera un
boom dans les découvertes technologiques
faisons en sorte que nous allons devoir
changer radicalement la société comme on
la connaît arrive très bientôt si ce que
nous prédit le mincult wale directeur de
l'ingénierie chez google et nous en tant
que futurs membres actifs de la société
ne sommes pas encore rendus là par
contre il est possible de l'être
en effet cette singularité propose
plusieurs problèmes tels que le fait que
nous allons devoir l'adapter mais celui
ci on se trouve sur trois aspects
premièrement nous allons devoir adapter
notre système scolaire à cette
éventualité
deuxièmement il va falloir ajuster notre
système législatif afin de préparer
l'arrivée de l'intelligence artificielle
et troisièmement il va falloir changer
notre perception quant aux
communications globalement commençons
par notre système d'éducation en effet
l'arrivée de l'intelligence artificielle
sur un milieu de travail
faire en sorte qu'il y aura beaucoup
d'automatisation des tâches
cela signifie que plusieurs emplois
globalement est plutôt un secteur de
ceux qui sont au salaire minimum vont
disparaître dans cette optique
comment nous en tant que simple être
humain allons-nous pouvoir
compétitionner avec des robots avec une
intelligence et une mémoire infiniment
plus performante que la nôtre la réponse
est simple grâce à notre expertise notre
créativité et notre individualité
individualités qui devrait davantage
être mises de l'avant dans notre système
d'éducation
vu qu'elle correspond à la voie de
l'avenir sur le millier de travail trop
souvent ces temps-ci le système
d'éducation est davantage synonyme de
d'échéancier de parker et de normes
plutôt que d'apprentissage
comment faire pour changer cette
perception des choses personnellement je
propose un système d'alternance
cela signifie des changes et des cours
du curriculum scolaire normal donc de
français de mathématiques peu importe
avec des cours d'activités en lien avec
les intérêts même de l'élève
par exemple une journée typique serait
composé de français par la suite
d'épreuves isation par la suite des
mathématiques par la suite de sport en
alternant et ses activités les élèves
seront davantage motivés à se présenter
à l'école et ainsi à se sentir valorisé
dans les activités qu'ils font cela
revient la question classique
il ne faut pas se demander ce qu'est la
société peuvent se faire pour vous mais
bien ce que vous en tant qu'individu
avec vos particularités vos différences
pouvait apporter à cette société en
deuxième lieu à bord dont le système
législatif le 21 et le 25 octobre
dernier sofia un robot humanoïde qrio
hong kong recevait sa citoyenneté
saoudienne cela correspond donc au
premier robot à recevoir une nationalité
et pas n'importe laquelle d'ailleurs
celle d'arabie saoudite un pays disons
questionnable en termes de respect des
droits humains
voilà pourquoi des milliers de personnes
deux hommes et deux femmes s'en sortir
dans la rue en se posant une question
assez simple comment se fait-il qu'un
robot puisse avoir plus de droits et des
libertés que nous et la question est
tout à fait légitime
pourquoi prendre du temps pour adapter
un système législatif tandis que nous
savons pertinemment que des millions de
personnes voient leurs droits
fondamentaux bafoués à chaque seconde
c'est vrai par ailleurs il faut
réfléchir à la source du problème
les amants technologiques sont
imminentes et instoppable on ne
s'attaquant pas aujourd'hui à ces
problèmes on ne l'attend pas notre
système législatif
cela fera juste reporté à plus tard tout
cet aspect prenons un exemple concret
par exemple un robot humanoïde quelques
se fier à commettre un meurtre
quelle est sa responsabilité criminelle
est-ce que cela reviendrait à
l'ingénieur qui l'a formé est-ce que
cela reviendrait en tant que tel au
rebot il y a un immense blanc dans le
système légal
et si nous ne remplissons pas c'est les
crimes qui vont décider les remplir
par la suite il s'agit des
communications nous avons l'opportunité
de réussir à remplir et à améliorer les
erreurs qui ont été faites dans le passé
depuis la nuit des temps les gens
s'intéressent aux écrits qui
correspondent à leur manière de penser
par exemple au québec nous avons des
journaux particulièrement distincts pour
les personnes plus de gauche ou plus de
droite
par ailleurs vous avez probablement
entendu parler des algorithmes et sur
facebook et qui vont en sorte que les
nouvelles qui nous voyons sur notre
actualitté respondents être pignon
politique
ma question est simple pourquoi priver
la population d'une contre pignon nous
savons aujourd'hui que c'est grâce
justement à 7 contre opinion que nous
pouvons réussir à nous forger une
opinion nous mêmes ou une perspective de
certaines choses fondé et pertinente car
n'importe quelle mentalité poussé à
l'extrême peu à être dramatiques
prenons la supposition de hugo de garris
chercheurs en technologies français
selon lui la troisième guerre mondiale
sera créé en partie à cause de la
singularité technologique
je m'explique d'après ses recherches les
personnes qui sont pour les annonces et
de l'intelligence artificielle
opposeront se poseront à ceux qui sont
contre en voyons bien que dans ce futur
plusieurs pays détiennent la bombe
atomique
nous savons pertinemment que les
spécimens ne tiendra pas longtemps
voilà pourquoi elle est donc primordial
de commencer dès maintenant à savoir
communiquer si des questions aussi
fondamentales que celles ci vont diviser
notre population nous devons être en
mesure de nous écouter et de comprendre
les points de chacun des deux côtés
d'immenses défis sera notre génération
dans le futur et nous savons
pertinemment qu'il faut prendre le temps
de nous adapter et de comprendre ce
qu'ils sont pour réussir à bien les
vaincre voilà pourquoi je nous pose ce
défi en tant que génération nous sommes
capables de nous préparer à cette
éventualité et c'est pourquoi il faut
commencer
m
j'ai confiance en nous merci